[Musique]
Salut les Terriens Salut les Terriens
très heureux de vous retrouver notre
invité principale ce soir c'est Benoît
Hamon
Benoît Hamon bonsoir
j'accueille ce soir le porte-parole du
Parti socialiste en quelque sorte on
peut dire que vous êtes le Frédéric
Lefebvre de la gauche non non vous
fâchez pas il va se barrer là
c'est un poste que vous avez remplacé
Julien Dray vous avez là
vous avez plus le droit de porter de
montres maintenant ou alors des swatchs
alors Benoît vous connaissez l'émission
on peut en nous serons tous les deux
nous parlerons de vous de vos origines
de votre enfance votre adolescence vous
engagements votre parcours jusqu'à cette
embellie actuelle du Parti socialiste
c'est parti socialiste qui gagne les
élections où chacun respecte ses
camarades où on se bat pas pour savoir
qui sera candidat en 2012
en P2 nous accueillerons de nouveaux
invités pour commentaires avec nous
l'actualité de la semaine Marc-Edouard
NAB pour son livre auto-édité L'Homme
qui arrêta d'écrire mais plutôt des
bonnes critiques ça doit l'inquiéter NAB
il risque de plus être l'écrivain le
plus détesté de France
Zemmour
toujours en P2 nous recevrons Laurent
Baffie pour son premier one man show au
Théâtre du Palais-Royal Laurent Baffie
est un sale gosse et nous profiterons de
sa présence sur ce plateau pour poser à
Laurent la question que tout le monde se
pose est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
continuer à porter des jeans et des
baskets après 50 ans
en P3 après le zapping et Guillaume nous
accueillerons notre invité du samedi 20h
ce soir Xavier Mathieu qui bossait à
l'usine continentale de Clairoix le
leader des Contis voilà l'émission
s'appelle Salut les terriens et le
groupe les grément de fortune
[Musique]
Benoît Hamon rebond ce soir alors c'est
quand même plus facile d'être socialiste
depuis quelques semaines non
plus
on peut enfin dire que les socialistes
en consommer de vous
plus besoin d'aller se faire aider aux
socialistes anonymes pour retrouver une
place descente dans la société
cela étant dit
faut qu'on reste calme
alors du Parti socialiste conseiller
régional d'Île-de-France et animateur du
courant un monde d'avance l'aile gauche
du PS alors pour vous faut moderniser la
gauche certes mais en restant de gauche
oui il y a un truc comme ça qui veut
qu'aujourd'hui que réformer ou
moderniser ça consiste en gros pour la
gauche
à se râler aux Axium de l'adversaire si
vous revenez au pouvoir donc vous vous
serez partisans de prendre plus d'argent
aux riches
alors que finalement ça a été le
discours de la gauche depuis toujours
quoi je sais pas pourquoi à la fois par
pudeur et par volonté plaire à des gens
qui de toute façon votre pas pour nous
et de toute façon mettre en tout en
œuvre pour qu'on comprenne pas le
pouvoir par volonté de plaire à ces
gens-là on en a oublié le cœur de ce qui
est notre action moi je suis pas pour
prendre l'argent riche juste pour
plaisir de reprendre de l'argent ces
gens-là sont de plus en plus riches et
il y a de plus en plus de problèmes dans
la société la question est de savoir
donc parmi les moyens qu'on a notre
disposition est-ce qu'on leur en prend
un peu plus et ben nous nous disons oui
si demain il doit y avoir une réforme de
la fiscalité qu'il se rassure on leur en
prendra un peu plus pas par souci de je
le dis c'est pas par sadisme les gars
des Russes c'est juste par souci de la
justice sociale mais il n'y a pas qu'à
eux parce que le sujet c'est pas juste
les riches c'est qu'il y a des gens qui
sont fabriqués la crise les banques
elles l'ont fabriqué elles ont plongé
parce qu'elles étaient au bord de la
faillite les États sont venus au secours
de ces banques on les sauve parce que
tous les États en payer pour sauver les
banques ils sont aujourd'hui en déficit
voir ruiner et qui spéculent après sur
la dette de ces états les banques c'est
ce qui se passe en Grèce ce qui se passe
au Portugal ce qui se passe en Espagne
ils gagnent à chaque fois à chaque fois
qui détient 60 % de la dette grecque les
banques françaises et les banques
allemandes nous nous disons puisqu'on a
un problème aujourd'hui de retraite il
est logique puisque ces gens-là dégagent
des profits qu'on mette en place une
taxe exceptionnelle qui ne concerne que
le secteur bancaire ils paieront plus
d'impôts sur les bénéfices des sociétés
que tous les autres entreprises parce
que c'est justifié au regard de ce qu'il
leur rôle dans la crise et le fait que
eux manifestement n'ont rien entendu à
ce qui s'est passé et continuer à
spéculer tranquille est-ce qu'on peut
dire qu'il y a un scandale des banques
en France en ce moment
ouais ouais il y a un contestablement un
scandale des banques mais ça peut se
régler et si vous regardez des deux
côtés de l'Atlantique en tout cas c'est
ce que le Parti socialiste propose en
France mais c'est ce que Barack Obama
lui veut commencer à mettre en oeuvre
c'est quoi le problème des banques c'est
qu'elles ont fait des profits pour
comprendre c'était pour elle-même avec
l'argent des déposants placer de
l'argent dans la banque vous lui
demandez de bien gérer votre compte en
banque et avec cet argent elle place de
elle le place et elle dégage et profits
qu'elles ne redistribue pas à vous avec
votre agent mais qu'elle se distribue à
ces traders à ses actionnaires etc mais
la solution qu'on propose c'est pareil
ce qu'on appelle la banque de détails
celle où vous déposez votre argent de la
banque d'affaires de façon à ce qu'il
n'y ait plus cette possibilité pour les
banques de faire des profils pour
elle-même avec l'argent des déposants
avec le risque qu'il y a qu'un jour si
elle chute ses banques bien que ce soit
vos dépôts qui disparaissent aujourd'hui
on est dans la privatisation des profits
et dans la nationalisation des pertes la
socialisation des pères alors on va voir
comment nous en est arrivé là
vous laissez le 26 juin 1967 à
Saint-Renan dans le Finistère comme
Nolwenn Leroy
oui SOS c'est vrai c'est vrai très
important ça vous rend extrêmement
sympathique je crois qu'on a du naître
la même clinique puisqu'il n'y a qu'une
clinique vous la connaissez pas du tout
bon alors
votre père était chef de travaux à
l'arsenal de Brest votre mère était
secrétaire quatre enfants à Brest vous
habitez rue Véronèse et pendant les
années lycée c'est le bitume de cette
rue qui devient votre univers en fait
c'est là que vous traînez en fumant des
cigarettes en faisant le monde je sais
pas si on a beaucoup fait le monde a
beaucoup Clopé ouais mais
ouais entraînait avec une bande de
copains
rebelle vous connaissez une scolarité
tranquille dans les écoles de Brest et
ensuite quatre ans à Dakar quand les
arsenaux de Brest envoie votre père au
Sénégal pour former des ouvriers là-bas
et là vous étudiez chez les Frères
Maristes avec des élèves noirs arabes
libanais et quand vous revenez en France
donc avec votre père parce que vos
parents ont divorcés votre mère restait
avec votre sœur à Dakar là l'uniformité
des classes vous heurte je reviens j'ai
12 ans et mon
c'est des petites détails de la vie mais
quand les parents ont choisissent en
Afrique de vous mettre à l'école
sénégalaise plutôt qu'à l'école
française qui aurait été en fait le fait
de transporter les écoles françaises en
Afrique qui font un choix qui a un choix
important parce que c'est vrai que ça ça
construit les enfants de manière
différente que si j'avais tourné entre
soi et le fait que quand je reviens
effectivement en Bretagne qui est une
région assez uniforme
la chose qui m'a le plus frappé c'était
que c'était effectivement uniformément
blanc mais vous percevez à ce moment-là
une haine du mélange quand même
ce qui est frappant c'est qu'on est dans
les années de monter du Front national
c'est que très vite après il y a à la
fois SOS Racisme d'un côté et puis le
Front National et moi dans mon lycée ce
que je vois c'est les badges la réponse
du Front national de l'époque je sais
pas mon peuple exactement et le déclic
de mon engagement est lié à cette à ces
années passées au Sénégal et à et au
sentiment que voilà
votre premier engagement réellement
politique en 86 au moment de la loi de
vaquer et là vous adhérez à lunettes
ensuite Mouvement des Jeunes Socialistes
et puis là c'est parti quoi
aujourd'hui vous êtes au sommet du Parti
socialiste porte-parole quand même c'est
bien
je suis assez fier de ça oui bien sûr le
problème de la à mon sens de la vie
politique française c'est la là aussi on
parlait d'uniformité c'est un peu
l'uniformité de ses élites
on parle aujourd'hui beaucoup de
diversité l'idée que l'assemblée soit
plus représentative de la mosaïque de la
France mais c'est vrai aussi sur le plan
social c'est à dire que on a beaucoup de
gens issus de milieux qui sont à peu
près les mêmes avec des trajectoires
assez semblables je pense que c'est sain
en tout cas ce serait ça que la
démocratie française se renouvelle pas
juste pour mettre des mecs de 40 à la
place des mecs de 50 qui remplaceraient
des femmes de 60 qui remplaceraient des
70 c'est pas d'avoir 10 ans de moins ça
fait vous rend pas moins con mais le
fait qu'il y ait de tout voilà et
aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est pas plus
mal qui est
Martine Aubry à la tête du PS Harlem
Désir qui a un parcours qui est un
parcours aussi qui est pas classique
comme numéro 2 du PS moi-même comme
porte-parole
ça ressemble un petit peu plus à la
française
il y avait beaucoup de gens qui étaient
issus du peuple aujourd'hui il y en a de
moins en moins
a déclaré Benoît n'a pas besoin d'être
numéro 1 car c'est maintenant l'idole de
toutes les femmes françaises quel que
soit leur âge des grands-mères au plus
jeune qu'est-ce qui lui a pris de dire
ça c'est pas c'est fou hein alors vous
avez dit d'ailleurs après mais comment
je vais gérer la situation maintenant
c'est quand la Première secrétaire du
PSD que vous êtes gens un playboy ou un
mannequin un top model comment comment
on fait ça vous met dans la situation
exacte qui peut être celle d'une femme
oui qui n'est pas jugé sur ses qualités
politiques par exemple et qui aurait
gravi les marches parce que leur aurait
ça fait un peu homoge quoi et c'est pas
très agréable vous voyez ce que c'est
maintenant
vous dites dans le passé martine a déjà
été mieux inspiré je l'avais dit ouais
bon depuis ça va on s'en est par là
je sais que vous aimez pas parler de
votre physique ceci dit c'est plus
facile de parler de votre physique que
celui de Martine Aubry
alors il y a comme une photo de vous
est-ce qu'on peut voir la photo il y a
une photo de vous sur facebook là vous
cherchez un peu quand même non
[Applaudissements]
comme vous êtes par ailleurs extrêmement
intelligent c'est pas grave voilà c'est
pas grave non
alors une dernière question porte-parole
du Parti socialiste c'est combien
d'abdos par jour
là en fait plus rien du tout il faut
être à la hauteur de cette image
je crois que je me relâche un peu là
attention c'est pas bon nous accueillons
Marc Edouard mAb
et non ma fille
alors
Marc douarnab bonsoir On dit beaucoup de
bien de votre dernier livre L'Homme qui
arrêta d'écrire ça vous inquiète pas
trop quand même ça repose
je me recharge c'est vrai que vous êtes
toujours tout fait pour être l'homme le
plus détesté de France je me souviens de
notre premier appareil si on médiatique
c'était chez Bernard Pivot en 1985 vous
étiez montré si violent avec Jean-Marc
Roberts que George Marc Benhamou
n'écoutant que son courage avait pris sa
voiture était venue sur le plateau pour
mettre un bourre quand même et puis
ensuite il y a eu vos papiers dans
l'idiot internationale journal de Jean
et dernier votre livre à la gloire de
Ben Laden lueur d'espoir oui j'ai tout
fait pour faire détester quand même non
je dis ce qu'il me semblait être juste
au moment précis où le temps passé
devant moi
vous dites il y a la beau gossitude de
Michael Vendetta moi je suis la seule
gossitude
c'est une belle phrase
la seule chose
alors donc ce livre l'homme qui a réta
d'écrire vous l'avez édité vous-même
vous avez marre d'un négligence des
éditeurs du boycott des libraires du
blackout de la presse vous en pouviez
plus là voilà j'ai inventé ce concept
d'anti-édition c'est quelqu'un qui
s'autoedite mais pas parce que les
éditeurs ne veulent pas de lui c'est
parce que lui ne veut pas des éditeurs
voilà c'est quand même la différence
c'est vrai que le système ne laisse que
10 à 15% à l'auteur pour vous c'est une
escroquerie a complètement 8% même parce
qu'ils disent que c'est la crise et
alors ils prennent ce prétexte pour
réduire mais vous savez en Amérique on
est en Angleterre c'est pas ça ça peut
atteindre 20% ce qui est déjà pas
terrible mais c'est mieux c'est plus
honorable vous dites il fait les biens
que quelqu'un siffle la fin de la récré
pour les parasites bah oui il y en a
marre de tous ces gens qui vivent sur le
dos de celui qui écrit qui produit qui
est qui qui souffre pour créer voilà
alors vous êtes devenu un [__]
d'éditeur et non parce que je suis à un
ange d'auto éditeur et vous hésitez
personne je ne suis pas éditeur mon
livre n'a pas de logo n'est pas
il n'y a rien d'autre que mon copyright
voilà c'est le texte qui m'appartient
j'en fais ce que je veux et je touche
70% de chaque exemplaire
que les autres réfléchissent à ça les
auteurs quand ils publient un livre ils
ont trois semaines pour faire des médias
pour qu'on en parle parce que et puis
trois semaines de visibilité dans les
librairies parce qu'au bout de trois
semaines les diffuseur ça repart moi il
y a pas de retour de livres et là sur ma
plateforme on le commande par internet
et on le reçoit 3 jours après on en est
à 3600 exemplaires aujourd'hui vous
voyez sans aucune boule bien sûr et puis
comme je touche beaucoup plus vous voyez
j'ai pas besoin aussi de vendre
énormément de livres ça se vend sur le
net ça se venge chez un fleuriste chez
un boucher oui chez un boulanger oui
dans un night club et dans une boutique
de fringues il y a des gens qui ne sont
pas
très capables de se servir d'Internet
donc je voulais qu'il y ait quelques
points physiques on puisse se trouver à
Paris mais ce sont des points
symboliques comme vous avez vu parce que
c'est ça qui est amusant c'est d'aller
chez le boucher au milieu des viandes on
trouve le livre et on le ramène chez soi
pour 28 euros et voilà et je tiens à
dire que ces points de vente ne aucune
commission voilà contrairement à ce que
font les livrez sur la bavette en
revanche alors le pitch voilà le
narrateur et l'auteur qui aurait arrêté
d'écrire un jeune blogueur se prend
d'amitié pour lui et l'entraîne dans une
visite du monde d'aujourd'hui voilà il y
a une visite de tout ce qui est horrible
pour moi dans le monde contemporain BD
entre autres
valve pour moi l'imposture généralisée
de notre époque ceux qui font croire
qu'il y a encore une culture possible
qui a encore un esprit possible qui est
encore finalement vous savez du fun
possible alors big BD dit il s'agit d'un
ramassis de Rago mondain et d'attaques
personnelles et il se demande en fait si
vous êtes le dernier écrivain libre ou
un aigri que la jalousie rend haineux
magnifique autoportrait magnifique
autoportée dans voici en plus c'est très
crédible mais bah ça me fait très
plaisir
alors
Laurent Baffie
Laurent Baffie mesdames messieurs
rebonsoir vous êtes ici ce soir parce
que ça y est le 7 mai vous serez enfin à
l'affiche de votre premier one man show
Laurent Baffie est un sale gosse au
Théâtre du Palais-Royal ça va Lolo tu as
combien de lexomiles par jour
non non pas de pas de cachet pour
l'instant personne n'a de cachait pas
même l'équipe technique on va faire deux
mois au Palais Royal et ce sont mes
adios musicaux
et voilà alors non mais l'idée c'est que
les gens se disent [__] j'y étais ça
va être un événement parce que c'est
totalement barré ça ça va ressembler à
rien et puis et puis pareil un petit
règlement intérieur on a droit des
sacrifices rituels des sacrifices
humains enfin je veux dire la police n'a
pas le droit de rentrer il va y avoir
vraiment tout ça à ma sauce donc faut
pas louper ce celui-là voilà
je peux en dire plus parce que si on dit
que tu montes nu sur ce mec plume dans
le cube en les gens ont d'attendre et
puis ils vont être déçus soit pas ton
cul soit par la plume je ne sais pas
mais autant garder la surprise c'est que
tu voulais l'appeler complet formidable
tu sais sur son film avec le bagnole et
fin seulement c'est n'y allez pas c'est
une merde personne n'est personne ça
s'appelle aussi Laurent Baffie fait sa
[__] j'ai une affiche
il va trop loin mais sur la tige est en
tout petit donc c'était pas tellement
vendeur donc il y a plein de projets
d'affiche est un sale gosse c'est pas
complet tu nous rassures c'est ça alors
on est deux hein
alors c'est au Palais Royal à partir du
7 mai c'est interdit au moins 12 ans
c'est parce que tu dis des gros mots tu
aimes pas les enfants bah non c'est
parce que quand j'attaque un un sketch
un peu sur la sexualité et en province
au deuxième rang il y avait une petite
fillette de 10 ans donc moi j'avais plus
envie de faire le sketch voilà il y a un
âge
limite pour voir ce SketchUp
bien j'ai pas de préféré malheureusement
Laurent c'est pas grand chose de sa vie
privée en fait il est moins je connais
très bien mais il est très pudique sur
sa vie privée
du Japon
oui ça c'est vrai ça oui oui c'est vrai
ouais avec des pintades aussi
alors on va faire un quiz Laurent tu
réponds pas on va voir si c'est
messieurs peuvent répondre quel est le
cri de la girafe
est-ce que quelqu'un dans le public peut
dire le cri de la girafe c'est pour le
faire briller c'est juste pour le mettre
en valeur Laurent la girafe est muette
mes
[Applaudissements]
dames
poisson contre le commandant Cousteau il
a gagné
au poisson
bien on passe maintenant aux
commentaires de l'actualité de la
semaine donc là on parle plus du tout
mon spectacle
non mais que les gens viennent les gens
à quelle heure
on passe maintenant aux commentaires de
l'actualité de la semaine avec l'édito
de Blacko et ses Bruno jeudi du Figaro
que nous retrouverons sur ce plateau
après le magnéto
[Musique]
les intégristes musulmans sentant de ta
merveille d'un côté portefeu est ravi de
montrer du doigt les mauvais français
pour flatter son électorat qui est
favorable à 84% à l'interdiction du
voile de l'autre les intégristes sont
ravis de passer pour des victimes ça
leur permet de prendre à témoin
l'ensemble de la communauté musulmane en
expliquant que décidément la République
n'aime pas les musulmans et
malheureusement avec Brice Hortefeux des
fois on est pas loin de le croire
on est en faut toujours un mais dès
qu'il y en a c'est quand même à beaucoup
qui a des problèmes sauf que le problème
en France ce n'est pas le nombre
d'Auvergnats c'est le nombre de chômeurs
pour 3/4 des Français le chômage et la
préoccupation numéro 1 du coup la burqa
c'est bien pratique pour cacher les
vrais problèmes de la France pendant
qu'on parle du voile on ne parle pas de
l'augmentation de 30 % du nombre
d'inscrits à Pôle emploi depuis un an
car apparemment le gouvernement a l'air
beaucoup plus préoccupé par la situation
de quelques centaines de pauvres
musulmans oppressés que par les
questions du chômage des retraites et du
pouvoir d'achat ça serait pas ce qu'on
appelle ce voile et la face voilà
c'était l'émission de Blacko mise en
image de Julien gras Bruno Joly bonsoir
vous êtes grand reporter au service
politique du Figaro et vous êtes
sarcologue alors vous avez fait plein de
bouquins Sarkozy les coulisses une
victoire Sarkozy de Neuilly à l'Élysée
Sarkozy et ses femmes et le 27 mai
paraîtra Sarkozy côté vestiaire sur le
sport voilà il va commencer Sarkozy ben
sur le plan politique qui n'est pas en
grande forme parce que dans les sondages
c'est simple il l'a jamais été aussi bas
aujourd'hui original il a perdu est-ce
qu'il a perdu en 2012 on peut pas le
dire aujourd'hui non surtout en plus en
campagne il est plutôt pas mauvais alors
on passe à la burqa bah oui c'est vrai
c'est encombrant une burqa on a du mal à
voir les 4 millions de chômeurs qui est
derrière
une bonne grosse diversion
et c'est une mise en scène qui sert
autant les intérêts du gouvernement donc
qui qui vise à essayer de reconstituer
le socle de son électorat à mes yeux que
celles et ceux qui profitent de cette
opportune tribune qui leur est offerte
par Monsieur Hortefeu c'est vrai qu'il
est il est bien casté le mec là il est
il a une belle barbe un beau foulard
palestinien les belles babouzes j'ai une
boucherie halal il a quatre femmes les
enfants partout ils l'ont vraiment bien
trouvé lui quand même
j'ai pas entendu de voix socialiste
s'opposer ils sont même prêt à voter la
résolution contre le port de la burqa
donc sur le fond sur le fond je pense
que Brice Hortefeux a raison nous on est
contre l'interdiction générale ça c'est
inapplicable vous allez faire quoi un
policier le Parti socialiste après deux
individus le Parti socialiste est contre
une loi d'interdiction générale après
une position mais non mais il y a des
services publics vous avez pas le droit
de dissimuler votre visage ça existe
déjà le vrai sujet c'est il y a déjà des
lois les lois qui permettraient d'agir
les utilise-t-il ces lois non le
gouvernement demande un avis au Conseil
d'État le Conseil d'État dit non pas de
fondement juridique pour faire une loi
d'interdiction générale il s'assoit
dessus et veut faire sa loi
d'interdiction générale que poursuit
comme objectif le gouvernement vraiment
lutter contre le port de la burqa ou en
fait avoir une loi une loi à faire des
grands débats vous avez vu qu'ils ont
fait une proposition pour qu'il y ait
dans toute la France des débats sur la
burqa c'est ça le sujet en ce moment
les Saoudiennes qui vont arriver et qui
vont faire leurs courses moi j'attends
qu'il y ait des flics qui arrivent et
qui disent à Madame il faut que vous
enleviez votre burqa avec les gardes du
corps derrière qui vont les tabasser les
flics devant nous sur les Champs-Élysées
là on va rire il y a pas de raison
d'empêcher la burqa à Saint-Denis et pas
sur les champs tu es pour ou contre le
port de la voile dans les régates toi
c'est vrai question parce que le mec là
l'IS et badge il a dit moi je suis pas
polygame 2013 et c'est vrai qu'avoir des
maîtresses en France d'un seul coup
c'est l'identité nationale quoi il est
parfaitement raccord
il veut s'intéresse gala il a lui fait
d'eau il est comme nous les musulman
adepte de Feydeau c'est magnifique ce
qu'on aime mais là en dehors de tout ce
qui est politique pour il faut arriver à
ce que savoir pourquoi toujours ça se ça
se fixe sur l'islam l'islam est comme un
miroir déformant de de cet Occident qui
est en phase terminale d'autodestruction
là la terreur que les Occidentaux
ressentent à la terreur de l'avenir et
transformer en peur du terrorisme
la le manque de foi total en tout y
compris en Dieu et transformer déformé
par le fanatisme religieux et cette
burqa moi je trouve que c'est que ces
symptomatiques de de ce que les
Occidentaux vraiment en fin de course
sont en train de se masquer ils sont
tous masqués ils sont tous eux
recouverts d'une burqa mentale pour se
cacher c'est comme si l'islam pour
l'occidental était une caricature de ses
propres tard
écoutez j'ai pas compris tout ce qu'ils
avaient dit c'est normal vous êtes au
figa
c'est que je sais pas quel est votre
choix de société mais en gros dans un
pays dans une République comme la France
a priori on n'a pas honte envie de vivre
dans un pays où la polygamie ou très peu
très peu de polygamie
sur la forme
alors que nous on voudrait pas de ces
femmes là même
sur la forme
pourquoi pourquoi la burka serait une
une espèce de d'alibi pour pour exprimer
son féminisme vous savez même pas ce qui
se passe dans la tête d'une femme voilée
alors alors arrêtez de vouloir appliquer
des lois sauf qu'il y a un sujet un tout
petit peu sérieux derrière ce qui est
une vraie caricature c'est que la burka
c'est quoi c'est que c'est la séparation
entre les l'homme et la femme le fait de
soustraire le corps de la femme au
regard mais si c'est ça peut-être que
vous voyez mais non moi je la vois pas
le sujet c'est pas le Coran mais non
c'est pas le courant c'est une figure
pas dans le courant
vous ne savez pas ce que si la femme se
voit c'est son rapport à Dieu ça n'a
rien à voir avec les autres elle s'en
fout des autres c'est son rapport
personnel à Dieu renseignez-vous sur la
religion musulmane et après vous pourrez
parler je vous rappelle juste quand même
monsieur madame le port
de la burqa est interdit est interdit à
la Mecque ça vous fera réfléchir un
petit peu sur ce que c'est que l'islam
soit voilée devant vous en quoi ça vous
gêne en quoi ça vous empêche la
connaître ça s'appelle la République et
l'égalité
c'est comme les [__] il y en a qu'on
oblige il y en a qu'on oblige pas non
mais bon
on est arrivé à ce genre de discours là
sur notamment la prostitution à la fin
et la comparaison c'est juste bon c'est
un petit numéro un petit peu ça fait
votre business là mais bon
vous en faites beaucoup de business
justement mais moi je pense que c'est un
sujet sérieux parce qu'il y a des femmes
justement qui n'ont pas fait cela et qui
n'ont pas fait cela et pour lesquels
aujourd'hui c'est une perte totale de
libre arbitre et pour ça la République
elle doit poser des règles et moi autant
je suis défavorable à une loi
d'interdiction générale parce qu'elle ne
serait pas applicable autant je reste un
adversaire par principe et au nom de
l'égalité homme-femme peu importe que ça
vous intéresse ou pas voilà je suis un
adversaire de la burqa d'Unica peu
importe du voile intégral d'ailleurs sur
ce point-là juste si cette loi est votée
et si elle doit pour qu'elle soit
validée il faut justement pas poser les
termes d'un point de vue religieux il
faut les poser du point de vue justement
de la dignité de la femme sur ces
questions là les questions d'ordre
public parce que sinon si vous allez sur
le terrain religieux devant le Conseil
constitutionnel ou d'autres juridictions
vous vous tomberez sous le coup d'une de
la validation alors le mec la liesse est
badge alors il est mort il dit je ne
suis pas polygame j'ai des maîtresses
c'est drôle c'est vrai que Brice
hortefer a peut-être pu éviter de
transformer ce personnage en une star en
un week-end c'est quand même ce qu'il a
fait c'est ce qu'il a fait si on aurait
pu s'en passer parce que lui faire cette
publicité bon en même temps faut
comprendre ils sortent feu et lui-même
un petit peu en position difficile dans
le gouvernement c'est très difficile de
passer derrière le président de la
République qui a été ministre de
l'Intérieur qui continue un peu à faire
ce job et du coup c'est assez difficile
pour lui des soirs le mec là c'est pas
possible le problème
il s'aventurer sur un terrain qui était
pas du tout bordé
peut-être qu'on peut dire aussi qu'il
est mal à l'aise depuis que le petit
film que vous avez montré le
réquisitoire dit ne le condamne pas mais
que le délit d'un juracial était
constitué bien on continue notre
commentaire de l'actualité de la semaine
avec l'édito de Blacko
[Musique]
pauvre Charles Pasqua il a passé toute
la semaine au tribunal faut dire qu'on
le soupçonne d'avoir bénéficié de
commission illicite pour financer ses
campagnes électorales et si la comparue
cette semaine devant la Cour de Justice
de la République c'est qu'au moment des
faits il était ministre de l'Intérieur
au sein du gouvernement Balladur bah
tiens Balladur justement lui aussi on le
soupçonne d'avoir bénéficié de
commissions illicites pour financer sa
campagne électorale ces libération qui
publient une enquête très très très
étayée sur le sujet mais bon tout le
monde sait bien qu'un nom encore plus
important que ceux de Balladur ou de
Pasqua se cache dans cette affaire allez
je vous donne un indice c'est un
président de la République c'est c'est
Jacques Chirac évidemment toutes ces
affaires c'est la faute à Chirac bah oui
réfléchissez Pasco est Balladur ont tous
deux trahi Girac en se présentant aux
élections contre lui j'ai décidé d'être
candidat à la présidence de la
République
parce que je crois en la France alors
forcément Chirac leur a coupé l'accès
aux pompes à fric du RPR du coup pour
payer leur meeting leurs affiches leur
tracts Pasqua et Balladur ont dû se
débrouiller comme deux grands garçons et
on voit le résultat quel vieux cowboy ce
Chirac on dirait qu'il a décidé de
flinguer tous ceux qui l'ont trahi
d'après vous ça sera qui le prochain sur
la liste
voilà c'était mes vidéos de Blacko mise
en images de Julien grappe c'est chaud
la fin
deux sujets d'abord il y a 10 millions
de francs en liquide versés au compte de
campagne d'Édouard il nous dit c'est
dans des meetings de l'époque que j'ai
récolté 10 millions de francs
ça veut dire que les militants de
l'époque étaient généreux ça veut dire
qu'il y avait de valeur de grosses urnes
dans lesquelles ils mettaient leurs
billets de tout ça c'est quand même une
hypothèse qui est une hypothèse à mes
yeux pas très crédible le deuxième sujet
le lien pourrait être fait avec une
rétrocommission liée à une commission
versée par l'État français à des
intermédiaires dans le cadre d'un marché
de sous-marin le problème c'est quoi
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a un juge
d'instruction qui s'appelle Marc
previdique qui enquête sur la mort de 11
français à Karachi direct
potentiellement lié potentiellement
puisqu'on ne sait pas à cette affaire de
vente puisque l'enquête est aujourd'hui
menée il demande ce juge que des
documents soient déclassifiés ils sont
secrets défense pour faire la lumière et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'a
déclassifié que de manière très
partielle et l'avocat des familles l'a
dit le juge lui-même a suffisante et la
question qui est posée qu'y a-t-il de si
secret de silou
dans ce secret dans ces informations
pour que le gouvernement ne les
déclassifient pas aujourd'hui là où le
juge demande à faire la lumière sur la
mort de 11 de nos compatriotes de la DCN
et de 3 de leurs accompagnateurs sur
place si c'est effectivement lié à
vente de sous-marin au Pakistan
là il faudra que
la Clermont celle qui était impliquée à
l'époque devront s'expliquer et ils sont
aujourd'hui au pouvoir surtout que
Sarkozy a dit c'est grotesque c'est une
fable pensez à la douleur des familles
il nous dit c'est une fable ce lien
entre la vente des sous-marins et les
rétrocommissions soit moi je suis pas là
pour dire le président de la
républiquement mais il y a une manière
de faire la preuve que c'est une fable
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu scénario
quand même assez incroyable ça commence
en 93 Edouard Balladur autorise la vente
de trois sous-marins au Pakistan ils
touchent apparemment d'après ce que midi
ce Sénat les scénaristes ils touchent
des commissions
voilà pour financer sa campagne en 95 et
puis pas de bol en 95 séchera qui est
élu je décris rapidement lui il arrête
il stoppe le versement des commissions
et 6 ans plus tard les bénéficiaires
ceux qui auraient dû bénéficier de ces
commissions
font exploser un bus avec 11 français
donc le drame fini scénario incroyable
scénario donc Edward Balladur aura une
part de responsabilité dans cette
attentat et son bras droit de l'époque
Nicolas Sarkozy directeur de campagne
ministre du Budget donc la faire est
trop belle et dernier point vous
soulevez une question importante à la
fin c'est que pourquoi pas lever des
classifier le plus largement possible ce
croyance je suis d'accord sur ce
point-là la sagesse serait de
déclassifier de lever très largement le
secret défense Marc Edouard un mot là
parce que je te le trouve par rapport à
la burqa inintéressant au possible cette
semaine il y a qu'un seul sujet c'est
Zahia la [__] des Bleus merveilleux
merveilleuse affaire
merci d'avoir été avec nous Bruno on
vous laisse partir et nous accueillons
notre invité du samedi 20h ce soir
Xavier Mathieu bonsoir
alors Xavier vous êtes le plus
emblématique des responsables syndicaux
qui sont apparus ces derniers mois vous
êtes le leader des Contis ces salariés
de l'usine continentale de Clairoix qui
a été fermé pour être délocalisé en
Tunisie en Turquie en Roumanie et pour
manifester votre colère contre cette
fermeture vous avez avec vos camarades
saccagez la Sous-Préfecture de l'Oise à
Compiègne actes pour lequel j'avais été
condamné et vous êtes devenu un symbole
de la lutte ouvrière en France on n'a
pas saccagé la sous-préfecture parce que
la boîte est fermée c'est parce qu'on
s'est un peu foutu de notre gueule au
gouvernement nous a mené en bateau et
voilà c'est un petit coup de colère
voilà mais on en parlera 20h
en attendant j'accueille Stéphane
Guillon
c'est à VOUS Stéphane pour la semaine le
dimanche
[Musique]
en Une de Paris Match Zaya se confesse
j'étais le cadeau d'anniversaire de
Ribéry c'est classe comme cadeau parce
que généralement c'est pas trop quoi
offrir un pull un parfum un DVD
prostituée c'est classe puis c'est elle
qui ouvre le paquet qui souffle la
bougie vous n'avez rien à faire
parle du tempérament de Ribéry il met le
feu
tu as toujours été meilleur à
l'extérieur qu'à domicile Ribéry à
l'extérieur il se lâche il enchaîne les
mouvements les exploits techniques à la
maison il joue pépère classique en
retrait on sent qu'il se fait chier
toujours dans match Barbara à accompagné
Jean-Paul Belmondo à Hollywood cette
semaine match ils ont fait une spéciale
anniversaire tout le monde peut montrer
le cadeau qu'il a eu
au Nigeria 300 condamnés vont être
exécutés pour désengorger les prisons en
France avec 115 suicides par an on a pas
ce problème les prisons s'autorégules
salarié de France Télécom rate sa
tentative de suicide ça c'est les boules
c'est les boules
se rater alors qu'on fait partie d'un
groupe qui comptabilise autant de
suicides réussis à mon avis ils vont le
virer pour leur image c'est super
mauvais super mauvais
quand tu présentes un tel taux de
réussite tu gardes pas une brêle qui te
nique ton bilan non
le Nouvel Obs consacre saüne aux grandes
personnalités devenues françaises parmi
elles réellement Domenech son papa était
espagnol oh merde
il y a pas moyen de déchoirs de Ménez
pour polygamie pour incompétence non
pour nullité non non et juste parce
qu'il nous énerve non non non non non
non
ah on me dit tirer dans mon oreillette
que de toute façon l'Espagne ne veut pas
le récupérer
une pub utilisant l'image d'une Citroën
Némo à comparer le président Sarkozy à
une petite voiture
faites comme Carla clam la pub prenez un
petit français
cette semaine
lors d'un crash test la fameuse Citroën
Némo s'est retrouvée sur le toit au bout
du deuxième virage ah bah ouais bah
ouais c'est le président tout craché
petit imprévisible et multipliant les
sorties de route c'est lui c'est lui
la FIFA aradié l'équipe de foot féminine
d'Iran les joueuses voulaient jouer
voilés au prochain JO de la jeunesse
est-ce que exceptionnellement l'équipe
de France pourrait jouer en burqa en
Afrique du Sud c'est juste pour que les
commentateurs sportives des autres pays
se foutent pas de notre gueule hello est
loin qui a marqué avec la main et Louis
il est nul mais comme il a inventé
c'était son cadeau d'anniversaire très
très belle équipe de France
Christophe Hondelatte va chanter au
petit gymnase et Sébastien Cauet démarre
son one man show faites vous les deux
dans la même soirée Hondelatte Cauet et
terminé par un fast-food une vraie
soirée de merde ça peut être un trip
on termine Thierry avec un appel celui
du professeur Lantieri dans Le Parisien
on manque de donneur pour des greffes du
visage il faut que les personnalités
montrent l'exemple on peut avoir
quelques idées de visage possible
Laetitia Casta ouais très bien très très
bien
Arielle Dombasle très bien aussi
quelques petites restauration dommage
c'était mieux avant mais c'était une
Boutin oui oui oui faut pas être
difficile on manque de donneur donc oui
oui c'est mieux que rien ah non à la
main maintenant non non non non non non
les enfants n'ont pas le droit de donner
leur visage en dessous d'un mètre 40 on
prend pas c'est non
DSK oui très bien très bien attention
quand même toutes ces anciennes
maîtresses vont vous contacter ça peut
être très fatigant attention
Frédéric Mitterrand ouais pas mal pas
mal et puis si vous aimez voyager à
Bangkok c'est le roi du monde tout le
monde le connaît
non non non non non non non non non non
non
prodige porter l'idée de la grève c'est
d'aller mieux pas d'être moins bien
merci à la semaine prochaine
et d'ici là sur
canal+.fr
on passe maintenant à notre amitié du
samedi 20h
Xavier Mathieu rebonsoir vous êtes né le
15 mai 1965 à Paris dans le 14e et votre
grande gueule je voulais tenez de votre
père un auvergnac qui se pose à
Tracy-le-Val dans l'Oise en 68 pour
gérer un chantier de charbon vous dites
mon père c'était l'emmerdeur public
numéro 1 mais ouais c'est du coup comme
quoi la génétique ça laisse des traces
c'est vrai que votre père c'était un des
premiers à faire chier les patrons avec
l'amiante tout ça ça fait sans exagérer
au moins 35 ans que je l'entends parler
par mon père qui refusait déjà
d'utiliser des gants en amiante à
l'usine qui voulaient absolument mettre
des masques quand ils touchait l'amiante
et tout qui refusait et qui se faisait
traiter de d'emmerdeurs publics
de rester assis ou de vous taire vous
aimez pas trop l'école vous arrêtez à
l'âge de 16 ans faites un CAP de boucher
vous devenez boucher et à l'époque vous
venez d'avoir un enfant et les 4500
francs par mois que la boucherie vous
rapporte c'est pas assez
ça tombe bien continental le fabricant
de pneus décide d'embaucher 300
personnes à 7500 francs par mois c'est
comme 3000 de plus par mois c'est pas
mal mais le problème c'est qu'il faut
faire les trois huit bah toutes les
semaines tu changes d'horaire tu bouges
jamais la même heure tu te couches
jamais la même heure tu vois tes gosses
un jour sur deux une semaine sur deux
des fois tu les vois pas et voilà donc
j'ai appris avec stupéfaction qui est
des gens qui savaient pas ce qui était
les trois huit ont flingué votre famille
quoi ouais je pense que j'ai pas été un
bon père je pense enfin
j'ai pas été vraiment un bon père
vis-à-vis de mes enfants parce que j'ai
pas toujours été là j'ai la fatigue a
fait que voilà j'ai pas été forcément un
bon père même si ils disent que c'est
pas vrai même si mes enfants sont fiers
de moi aujourd'hui moi je pense que
j'aurais pu faire beaucoup plus pour eux
voilà alors la souffrance à l'usine
c'est pas seulement les trois villes
c'est pas seulement le rythme de travail
ou les changements de rythme de travail
c'est encore pire si la souffrance
physique c'est-à-dire les tendinites les
douleurs dans le dos le problème de
vertèbres les cordes broyer des ouvriers
alors dans le temps les les anciens
c'était les travaux forcés bon c'était
pas mieux mais aujourd'hui c'est c'est
des travaux qui sont toujours répétitifs
répétitifs répétitifs et les
articulations les tendons pètent ne
tiennent plus on dit quand on parle des
retraites que la durée de vie s'allonge
mais pour les ouvriers la durée de vie
s'arrange pas c'est toujours 3 64
non mais je pense que le moi tu sais
j'ai vu
j'ai vu j'ai vu pendant des années
des potes partir à la retraite et puis
j'ai vu pendant des années sur le
panneau à l'entrée des informations tel
potes étaient morts deux ans trois ans
après alors les horaires de merde les
boulots crevant il y aurait de quoi
détester son son travail pas du tout au
contraire si elle est les ouvriers
adorent le usine ils sont fiers de
bosser à continental la machine qui leur
casse le dos il l'appelle ma machine
comme ils disent ma femme ou mes gosses
quoi c'est c'est attachement incroyable
à cet esclavage quand on les mecs parler
de leur machine tu sais les mecs ils se
sont battus c'est pas seulement pour
sauver leur famille aussi c'était pour
c'est leur usine c'est leur boîte tu as
des mecs ça fait un an un an et demi tu
en as plein il passe même plus par
l'usine le chemin de l'usine il évite
ils peuvent pas c'est un traumatisme
mais grave alors le premier souci que
vous avez rencontré chez Conty c'est un
an après votre arrivée quand la
direction va augmenter les cadences
voilà vous gueulez mais vous n'êtes pas
encore syndic à l'époque hein j'étais un
des premiers ouvrir ma gueule et puis à
l'époque j'ai fini la CGT parce que j'ai
failli me faire virer par le patron et
c'est la CGT qui m'a défendu donc je me
suis dit le 11 mars 2009 donc la
fermeture de l'usine est annoncée et
pour ça le directeur allemand fait le
déplacement et il dit pensez aussi aux
actionnaires eux aussi ont besoin de
faire des bénéfices pour vivre c'est sur
Alice ouais j'ai mis le paquet de
kleenex dans la gueule tu sais on parle
de radicalisation partout en France mais
moi je voudrais quand même tirer un
sacré coup de chapeau à tout la classe
ouvrière parce que la radicalisation il
y en a pas eu
de de drame si chez les ouvriers chez
France Télécom tu vois il y a eu des
suicides il y a eu il y a plein de gens
qui se suicident qui foutent l'envie en
l'air j'ai compté il y a déjà des
nombreux divorces
c'est quand même 27 millions d'euros de
bénéfices quoi je veux dire ça va pour
eux quand même ils sont pas ils sont pas
là quand même alors là bon quand on vous
annonce la fermeture de l'usine vous
commencez à pas dormir ou dormir trois
heures par nuit ah ouais ouais c'est
c'est un combat c'est un des combats de
c'est un des combats de notre vie
ce que peut penser et j'ai remarqué
souvent j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
leaders de luttes et c'est un peu tous
les mêmes tu sais on est tous des
Grandes Gueules mais à la fin à
l'intérieur c'est c'est chamallow c'est
je suis un bileux un bileux comme c'est
pas possible quand je me couchais
j'arrive pas j'arrive pas à dormir de ce
qui s'était passé la veille et
j'arrivais pas à dormir de ce qu'elle
est passé de lendemain alors le pire
c'est qu'en échange de cette non
fermeture les ouvriers de Continental
avaient accepté en fait des sacrifices
les gens ont accepté de revenir à 40
heures c'est le travailler plus pour
gagner plus et dans cet accord de 40
heures aussi ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'il y a eu aussi le les transferts de
charges qui est une loi de Sarkozy c'est
à dire qu'on transfère par exemple des
primes des primes de vacances ou des
primes de fin d'année en intéressement
pour plus payer de charge et il y a
aussi la loi TPA sur les heures
supplémentaires qui ont été un véritable
fiasco puisque on sait ce que comment ça
finit en fin de compte tu fais des il y
a des chômeurs et on faire des heures
supplémentaires aux gens et en plus par
le par le même biais on veut faire
travailler les gens plus longtemps enfin
c'est oui c'est des choses que on
n'arrive pas à comprendre alors les
ouvriers évidemment refusent la
fermeture vont devant les tribunaux
persuadés qu'ils vont gagner mais le
verdict est favorable à continental et
là la colère explose incontrôlée quoi et
c'est le saccage de la Sous-Préfecture
de l'Oise à Compiègne tu sais je vais
dire c'est le le désarroi des gens il a
été à l'auteur de l'espérance qu'ils
avaient joint personne n'a envisagé une
seule seconde qu'on allait perdre ma
seule erreur si je peux en avoir une
c'est d'avoir annoncé dans la
sous-préfecture qu'on avait perdu mais
étant et moi j'ai pas réfléchi une seule
seconde ça explose et voilà le seul fait
choper en fait vous avez été filmé il y
avait cette télé ce jour-là avant il y
avait canal il y avait la 5 la 6 France
2 France 3 tout était là TF1 à la fin
tous sont venus nous voir nous disant
toutes les images seront floutées
sauf une il y en a qu'une enfin une qui
l'avait dit qu'il a pas faite c'était F1
ce qui est marrant c'est le jour du
tribunal même le président du tribunal a
dit magnifique pour une fois c'est
facile de travailler avec des images
pareilles il sait pas lever mais presque
il a regardé dans la salle il a fait
merci TF1 c'est fort quand même c'est
pas bon vous avez votre tripartite ce
qui veut dire que l'État intervient il
vous laisse plus vous face à continental
donc l'État intervient du tripartite
vous décidez à ce moment-là du plan
social négocier quand même sorti là
50000 euros doublement des indemnités
légales congé de conversion de 80%
jusqu'à fin 2011
par rapport à un plan social voilà on
aurait préféré tout ce que notre cuisine
reste debout mais la lutte à payer
l'exemplarité de la lutte ça a été une
véritable démocratie ouvrière tous ces
décisions de l'assemblée générale nous
les les délégués on s'est mis minable ça
veut dire que moi je représentais plus
que moi-même c'est à dire que quand
j'allais en assemblée générale il y
avait 900 mecs il y avait 900 mecs qui
votés pour leur peau voilà justement
vous en tant que délégué syndical vous
auriez pu profiter d'un système de
licenciement beaucoup plus favorable en
fait mais vous êtes dit non moi je vais
être traité comme les autres ouais il y
en a tout le monde n'a pas fait choix on
est trois ou quatre de la CGT avoir
demandé à l'inspecteur du travail à être
traité comme les 1120
voilà mais c'est normal moi j'ai signé
un accord c'est normal mais c'est bien
quand même alors on procès du saccage de
la sous-préfecture il y a un certain
nombre de témoins de moralité qui sont
venus Marie-George Buffet Olivier
vezancenot Cécile Duflot Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et hasard parce que on vous a
pas du tout invité pour ça tous les deux
vous étiez là Benoît ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas eu la pression
avant de parler on fait des télés on
parle etc et là
c'est quand même une bagarre exemplaire
qu'ils ont conduite et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que tout le monde est venu
alors résultat des courses donc les
dégâts ont été estimés à 52000 euros bon
voilà trois bureaux l'état dit
l'assurance
[Applaudissements]
sur le fait qu'on dise que j'ai reproché
à Thibault de pas être venu dans l'usine
j'en ai rien à cirer c'est pas ça la
vérité à la limite qu'on dise que c'est
pas son boulot ouais c'est pas son
boulot c'est pas son boulot non plus à
lui qui est aux autres politiques et
sont venus ils sont venus mais je
voudrais que remercier quand même la
Fédération de la chimie parce que eux
ont toujours été là depuis le début
ensuite il y a la proposition de
reclassement que continental est obligé
de vous faire où on vous propose 137
euros par mois pour aller travailler en
Tunisie bon là ce qu'il faut dire quand
même alors des charges c'est qu'ils sont
obligés de le faire et que les les
chaussettes Olympia qui l'ont pas faits
ont été condamnés à 2 millions et demi
d'euros d'amende sauf qu'il y a encore
un coup tordu là dessous c'est que le
Medef et le grand patronat ça fait des
années que que comment dire que
l'obligation de reclassement ils veulent
le virer alors ils font exprès justement
de proposer des des situations tellement
inaccess incroyables que justement ils
veulent se mettre autour de table pour
dire là vous avez vu c'est qu'on est
obligé de faire ça c'est dégueulasse
pour tout le monde se met autour d'une
table et vire cette obligation de
reclassement ensuite on retrouve les
comptines dans toutes les luttes qui a
eu donc vous êtes devenu un petit peu
les Robins des Bois là chez new Fabrice
et total chez Sodimatex chez Goodyear
honnêtement vous avez aucune chance de
retrouver du boulot moi je vais vous
dire je serai pas trop je vous prendrai
pas
je m'en branle moi je vais te dire j'ai
vécu j'ai 45 balais j'ai vécu la plus
belle expérience
sociale et humaine de ma vie quoi qu'il
arrive je vais dire je m'en fous moi ce
qui cherche dans la vie c'est pas la
fortune c'est la richesse et la richesse
ça vient d'ici ça vient de là le reste
je m'en fous c'est une baraque une
copine et ramasser des morilles voilà
c'est aller c'est aller aux morilles
avoir une une copine des enfants et puis
il y a une chose qui m'apporte dans la
vie c'est quant au bout de ma vie
restera la fierté de mes parents de mes
enfants et de celle que j'aime le reste
je m'en fous comme de l'enquête ça sera
le mot de la fin merci
un mot un mot
respect un mot marqué noir révolution
bah si un mot respect aussi
voilà c'était Salut les Terriens avec
Benoît Hamon porte-paro UPS merci avec
Marc Edouard NAB pour l'homme qui a réta
d'écrire qu'on trouve sur internet
Laurent basic bon Laurent Baffie est un
soldats au Palais Royal à partir du 7
mai à 21h Bruno du Figaro et Xavier
Mathieu le leader des comptines bravo
merci à toute l'équipe qui m'a aidé à
faire cette émission on se retrouve
samedi prochain à 19h et d'ici là sur
canal+.fr je vous laisse avec les amis
de Groland et d'Action Discrète Salut
les Terriens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu